I'm looking at your desk how do you get
any work done I mean you've got so many
[__] mementos that's all behind me
Howard it's my my desk is in front of me
look at that little microphone
what is that why do you have that
it's not even a real microphone why
would you have a toy microphone on if
you we know we're in radio
microphone in there right he's got the
real Michael yeah good you threw it out
there it is
all right that's what else you got show
me something else all right he threw it
out I like that what is that you're
holding up
what does that say
Throw it out so far two things are gone
show me the next thing what's that
orange cup why is that there yeah yeah
what is that it's a Reese's cup I got
all right somebody gave me a giant gift
bag with a bunch of Reese's stuff
good all right what else you got there
pick out another thing what about the
Jets helmet do you really need that I
don't need it all right throw it out
he's got a little baby Jets helmet right
that's not big enough to fit on his head
it's gone you'll never miss it
what is that
I would throw it out I would already
your desk is looking better now what how
many photographs you have there I see
one of you and Mary okay they're all
family photographs keep one and get rid
of the rest but you don't know what your
family looks like he's got 57 pictures
of his family what else he got look how
nice his desk is starting to look look
at the space he's got I know but Howard
I don't use that space I don't I have a
space in front of you you're gonna use
it I guarantee you you're going to use
it but someone's gonna come in and
you're going to go oh here lay it all
out on here you're going to use it what
is that jar peanut butter throw it out
it's old we're not even gonna eat it
there's a plenty plenty of junk back
there behind his head do I need that
Howard book all right that you could
leave that's a good promotion yeah that
should be in there Gary what's right
next to you your hand there what what's
all this [__] it's a ton of stuff it's a
it's a a drinking mug a steak
what do you staple put your stapler in
your drawer like like he's stapling
every minute yeah I got a staple so much
yeah it says the Mets or something I
could go in there and clean up that
office in three seconds well I could too
Howard I don't need to have all this
because the other stuff on top of the
case what is that yeah what is on top of
the case
um there's a giant Hershey's kiss and
somebody throw that out you don't need
that like a hole in the head what else
is on top of that trumpet case what do
you got it was a Foo Fighters
promotional thing it's a little term
throw it out stop it the proof fight
what are you in the Foo Fighter when
you're in the Foo Fighters he won't take
the kids down no I will I mean take it
out throw it out throw it away throw it
away and take the clutter in this guy's
office that's painful to him Robert if
it was painful to me I would already ate
it
I see a lot more potential things to be
thrown out but okay you did a good job
Gary yeah as you can see the desk now it
looked like a landfill right his whole
work area looked like like like there
was an earthquake oh my God I'm so sorry
I'll tell you how crazy Gary's office is
Gary's already thrown out one desk
nameplate that said Baba Bowie and
there's another one of the trumpet case
there's like now another one look at
like what does that one say what is that
Gareth executive throw it out you don't
need did you know your name you
literally gave it to me why did I give
it to you it's an embarrassment why I
had to give that to you you kept
forgetting your name I said here
all right now you look a little more
professional priority must be a neat and
orderly mind in office yes sir what I
see when I see that old office is the
cluttered human being who's confused but
you see I do not like busting Gary's
balls I don't know you will feel bad
after today is that what you're saying
what you think I want to spend 45
minutes of my show cleaning Gary's desk
[Music]
foreign